yeah he's just like having sentences
just yeah just say something yeah
taco what did you see
he just woke up he's in a grumpy mood
you big cuny guy
he was saying
i see cars over there
these cars
and then we're like oh yeah really
really buddy
get out of the way babe which way
oh yeah there's cars there really are
cars
ohio
so today we're going on a hike it's
called gold strike hot springs trail
and apparently there's actual hot
springs at the end of it so you can take
off your clothes and take a nice little
dip but it is a strenuous hike so i
don't know if we can make it with a
little dude because it's supposed to be
like
over three hours to complete
but we still just wanted to get
acquainted with it to see what it's like
and maybe we can actually make it but
this one's called gold strike canyon
and look at that
joe when you're looking at a map what
are what do you look for
for me
oh my god what are you doing
oh my god
oh my god what the [ __ ]
what
[Laughter]
so in the middle of me asking joe a
question i see hannah's line so i looked
down and then
i got his dick out for some reason all
right so back to the question what do
you look for on the map obviously not
children's dick yeah but um
so we're here at the visitor center yeah
i'm trying to figure out where this
trail leads to oh yeah where the hot
springs are huh yeah and then our way
back just in case we get lost true and
our phones don't work that's true
you need to go to jail dude yeah you can
go to jail dude you want to go to jail
you can't pull your pants down whatever
you want you have to tell me and then i
take you okay
you didn't tell everybody i thought he
was grumpy too
we're vlogging here
where are you guys going
where are you going what are you gonna
do over there they're gonna go nate do
nature's call
hey
make the baby they're gonna make a baby
they're gonna make a baby monkey you're
gonna have more cousins hey this way
this way
follow me
okay i'll follow you let's go to the
cave no no no over here oh there's caves
over there
no they have to go creepy yeah they have
to go people you have to leave them
privacies
i think they told me to follow you now
you need help
okay
[Music]
all right guys also rocking the new
barber gate stretch cargos these are
super comfy i designed these to fit in
all kinds of circumstances
travel work tactical and also hiking so
one of these hiking they stretch
they're also like this uh grid rip stop
material so it's very durable and
there's all kind of utility pockets like
this right here
exactly and then you have a covert
pocket when traveling see this those
pickpockets always want to lift up for
flaps and when you lift up the flaps
what do you get nothing
a nice grab ass grab good job right here
and also you don't even need a belt so
it makes it easy when you travel so
check it out
uh it's very comfy
and uh back to the schedule programming
oh taika are you climbing this big rock
you're scared i think you could do it
just gotta keep trying
what are some words of encouragement for
your young child trying to climb a rock
you can't do it dude just stop hey just
stop you can't do it you saw you so the
crowd has spoken
the crowd has spoken
good luck
see what theo's doing no
what's your head i don't know i know
that's not nice life is not nice
monkey he's just playing with you
he's playing with you it's a joke it was
a joke he's playing
who's handy
he's just playing with you okay i'll
help you he's just playing with you
monkey he's just jokes
he's a professional clown we all love it
all right yeah look at the size which
side's the easiest that's oh that's a
good side
all
so you don't even need my hand dude
see you don't even need my hand
good job
see that's how you teach kids yeah
good job
look mama good job dude
good job duty
you get down yeah
okay
good job look how big this rock is
that's a big old rock he did all by
himself
did you need my hand
good job just one step at a time i know
there you go you can jump from there
dude
just gonna scrape your pee pee all over
the rock watch out okay just let go
there you go good job wow
that's amazing
so far it's a pretty cool trail we're
right on the other side of hoover dam
and when we're driving i actually missed
the exit the first time and you take
this freeway right here
and right when you cross that freeway
onto the other side
it's crazy because you're in arizona so
you could literally cross from nevada to
arizona in like 30 minutes because this
is about 30 minutes from our place which
was crazy and then when i turned back
around it says welcome back to nevada so
we popped in two states in like 30
minutes which is something i'm not used
to but it was cool to like go on a mini
road trip back and forth
and you just follow this path and you go
all the way down that way those guys are
shirtless
so i'm assuming they went to the hot
springs
unless they're just sexy hot vapes
trying to show off
in front of my wife
i always love running forward because i
like seeing him catch up to me
you're so good dude i think he's
following you and you're fast look at
that we're way ahead of the pack
they're barely crossing over
right there
you're doing a good job dude oh you're
gonna leave the pack okay
there he goes
this is so candy because if i'm running
i'm like jumping over folders jumping
over rocks and stuff i'm like this
stuff's definitely gonna slow him down
but as he's getting older he's
definitely getting way more athletic so
he's keeping up real good look
he's already in front of me
and i can't even see where he is
where is he
[Music]
there he is
what is that
those car parts
you see something
what oh there's a carport down there
that is a car
whoa
there's a car there's an axle over here
what where down there
whoa
yeah i wonder if that's car parts i fell
down from a car wreck
whoa
be careful deal joe
whoa look at theo joe he's going all the
way up there to the car wreck
thank you for loving him
oh my god he didn't say that
he said don't ruin our day by dying oh i
see is that what he meant
i didn't know he was so sarcastic at
four years old
well he's going all the way up there
yeah you went away
wow you should oh
holy moly there's another car over there
another one
and then another one over there
how do you think these keep happening
mama i don't know you think just crazy
drivers and they fall off the freeway
over there
damn
that's scaly
[Applause]
how do you like seeing tycho running
around
i like it it's just right now he has
this cough yeah so it just makes me sad
that i can't coat his throat with
anything i know i think right now since
it's like when he's active it kind of
like tickles his throat a little bit and
then makes him cough because he's still
recovering i feel bad
but i mean i like him being outdoors i
love being outdoors this is really cool
i like seeing his little agility like
improve every single time yeah he's not
doing so much of an up-down run anymore
he's doing a little bit of a forward run
just a little bit and there's a lot of
stuff he could climb on his own now
whereas everything where he made it by
himself yeah before he needed he yeah he
always needed help now he just needs a
little more help uh going back down but
on the way up he's doing really good
look
good job duty
you little mountain goat
good job
don't go too high up dude
say don't worry i'm a mountain goat
is so good with him too
she's a good aunt
yeah she's a really good auntie this
kitty he has good peels and pias around
him huh yeah
some of them are bad influences
like who
joe
talking to you
no he's not a bad influence it's just
they're both they're two kids and one
one kid eggs the other one on then it
goes gnarly and you know
we're like hey calm down both of you
calm down do you both want time out
yeah look he's taking him up
[Music]
look how cute this guy looks he's
keeping track of his stuff it's not
funny at all it's good it's responsible
good job
a little cute backpack dude
he has a satchel yeah
i finished the hike about to grab some
yummy lunch and joe was on yelp and he
found this place called crab corner and
it had hell of reviews look at that
four stars
over a thousand reviews
so we're gonna check it out um
hey blondie
hi
the menu looks delicious look at that
crab cake sandwich lobster rolls lobster
grilled
water
with a lot of ice i can't make up my
mind because i was looking at the
alfredo with shrimp
marilyn style seafood
so you want to order the sampler i do
because i saw this picture oh man
where'd it go
[Music]
yeah so look at this
it comes with
corn crab legs shrimp
and just the fact that it's garlic oh
yeah
yeah
hannah and joe's been talking about
lobster rolls this whole time so i can't
get that too
[Music]
hey monkey what's the hammer for
a quack
so we gotta cut now so we can share
oh yeah
oh man you don't talk to me like that
yeah yeah
yeah
oh thank you
yeah
is it good
it's a lunch time baby here we go
okay you could do the lemon
oh yeah
okay
let's go vinegar on our chips
okay you use it as ketchup
you do it instead of ketchup
yeah but i don't know if this is gonna
be the same because we do it on the
thick chips what about with tartar sauce
you do with tartar sauce
so just our chips huh yeah but the i
don't think it's going to work because
these aren't like it's not going to wear
oh that's good
let me try
are you sure it just tastes like okay
baby vinegar and sea salt
is it good
yes i'll pass it's good really i like it
i'm like
mmm
kinda has like a salt and bit i see
where they get salt and vinegar chips
from yeah that makes sense
oh yeah garlic steamer
enjoy enjoy let's do it
we're waiting for our rice oh yeah
it's pretty good can't wait to smash the
grabber
sauce is really really freaking good she
said that it's to die for is it to die
for it
is it yeah oh yeah
okay let me see you break a crab you
know how to break a crack
smash it with your little hammer yeah
good job
okay maybe this one
go right here this part right here
hard hard
good job
okay
and then you eat the meat you're gonna
get this yeah
squeeze it
squeeze it squeeze wait okay open again
not so much a little bit okay there you
go
squeeze squeeze squeeze squeeze hey good
job
good job dude
and i can eat the yummy the yummy stuff
on the inside
good
job
all right guys
so this is teamwork time
because we got a big booboo
taika what do you have a splinter a
sharp winner splinter
so it's on his thumb how did it happen
and we want to take it out but you're
scared huh
i'm sorry mister but we got to take it
out cause it's gonna hurt right now it
might get infected it might get infected
but if we take it out you know what's
gonna happen it might hurt a little bit
but it's gonna feel good in the long run
yep okay mister
get out yeah do you trust mama and papa
but keep putting the baby right here
oh yeah right after we're done we're
gonna give you a nice band-aid it is
bleeding i know we're gonna we're gonna
clean you up
i know can we can we can we take it out
for you
you want to keep it in there what if it
gets infected it hurts even more
infected it means you you have it's a
wound that gets open like it's bleeding
then germs get in there and the germs
inside have a party and then the germs
they it starts getting really big and it
hurts and it turns purple and there's
plus everywhere and everybody i'll be
putting the baby on the blood it's not
gonna know it's gonna come in there no
it's not gonna do anything because you
have you have a big piece of wood in
there that's we gotta take it out first
once you take it out
once you take it out then it's okay
like oh you got distracted you hit the
crutching sound like a commercial and
then he was like wait what is that
so as you can see the splinter booboo is
much bigger in his head than it is on
his hands so the key thing is is to keep
him calm
and build enough trust so that he allows
us to
pull the splinter out because so far he
thinks
i don't know what he thinks he's for but
i think he's going to think the worst
where it's gonna be the most insane pain
he ever felt when we pull it out so what
i told him is
this is what's gonna happen
before we do anything i'm gonna tell you
first so you're aware so that way we
take away the unknown so i told them
it's a three-step process step number
one we take a look at your thumb what we
just did
step number two
we pull it out
step number three
we put the band-aid of your choice on
because he keeps emphasizing bandit he
wants a band-aid once abandoned so i
want to make sure that what he wants
which is a band-aid a nice band-aid is
part of the step process so it's not all
me so i think that calmed them down a
little bit because okay cool we already
did step one so that's one out of the
way the middle one is the part i hate
but right after is exactly what i like
so that's what we did so far and so
right now uh we're washing his hands to
make sure it's nice and clean and i let
him wash his own hands so that he
doesn't think i'm gonna rub his thumb
and hurt him and now it's the hard part
but after that it should be good but
when it comes to dealing with kids you
know
since parents know better
it's obviously really logical and easy
for us yeah you pull it out now you feel
the pain once then you don't feel it for
the rest of the day or the week or
whatever
you keep it in you're gonna feel it for
a long time kids don't know that right
it's like trying to teach kids like why
they can't have candy for every single
meal so i'm just trying to build that
trust calm them down so he feels good
and he feels like we do actually know
better and that's the hard part of
parenting
apple give me this thumb
then i'm gonna let let me talk first let
me talk first and then i'm gonna do this
okay no you don't know that's what i'm
saying let me talk first and then what
i'm gonna do
oh oh oh back
yes i'm using the back and i'm gonna try
to push it out like that
i'm gonna try to push it out okay yeah
did that hurt you
no no that's it
i'm trying to push this in here i'm
trying to push the splinter out of your
skin oh
yes that's all i'm trying to do
let me try okay
i know but let me try it
i know you've never tried it before it's
your first time but let's try
time i it it's your first time i'm going
to go slow and gentle okay
in the middle of the crap
you're a cartoon character dude oh my
god i know but now we have to let me try
you have to be brave
monkey monkey monkey
i know it's your first day but i believe
in you okay
i know you're a brave monkey dude
you're very brave me okay i know you
trust me that i'm not gonna hurt you i'm
gonna go
gentle want to try to be a niche here
trust you you don't trust me
so then what do we do you're going to
leave it in there and let it get
infected because it's going to keep
hurting
so what do you want to do
it's only it's not let's try it
all right it was a mission but we got it
done we're in step three which is put on
the band-aid good job monkey i'm so
proud of you you're so brave oh man you
did good you did really good you were
nervous huh
yeah but you did really good okay give
me a thumbs up
like this okay
okay how's that does that hurt come on
wow
do that that hurts oh
keep your thumb straight
i'm being very careful very careful look
at that
oh good job look at that that's nice
okay
is that gentle yeah
there you go
you're gonna live another day
you do good thank you
okay
probably can't just that you can't just
that over there that dirt no because
sometimes there's rusty nails in there
nails in there
you gotta be careful cause you wanna get
more splitters or cuts i would take the
nails out and then put them in the
magnet box
yeah this is infected i've had this
before
yeah i was trying to show what infected
is that we have to take him out we need
to show this to joe joe said he just
leaves him in there sometimes
another dangerous that that's a danger
bug yeah that is dangerous and what and
what and spiders are dangerous
look at my bed shoot mm-hmm you could
they could [ __ ] you you're right yeah
and you got my sleep yeah yeah we said
we stopped the vlog and then tacos can
you turn on the vlog camera again that
wasn't done
is that it was that your message yeah
just a little bit okay
can pebble turn it off now
okay
all right dude before we tell everyone
good night let me see your little thumb
how was it
it feels better does it hurt still no
did you just pick something up from the
floor and put your mouth
what was that
a mask
a mint
wait you didn't put the men off the
floor did you
well even through my hair
your inhaler yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy speaks so much now it's insane
it blows my mind he can have full-on
conversations not just with me but by
himself
but
on that note
tell everyone goodnight duty
whoa i had a cartwheel